the consultations are ongoing and uh
of course it is going to be
an inclusive system
we are in talks and we have
a
relationship a working relationship of
with the americans about the security
arrangement
and
the outside
checkposts are
in our control and
insight is under the control of the
united states forces
and they're in constant contact with one
another it is
very unfortunate
for people to be rushing to the airport
the way they are
at the moment
i think
it would have been much better
because we have announced
general amnesty for everyone the
security forces from senior to the
junior level
and this
fear all this hysteria that has taken
place
is unfounded the developments were so
fast that
all
people were taken by surprise
and when we
entered kabul and it was not
pre-planned because we announced
initially that we do not want to enter
kabul and we want to reach a political
solution before entering kabul
and
making a joint and inclusive government
but what happened was that the security
forces left and they abandoned their
places and we were forced to
force to ask our forces to enter and
take over security the point of
intra-afghan talks was precisely that we
come to a
to an agreement about what those rights
actually entail
sharia law is known to everyone
and there's no ambiguities about the
rights of women the rights of men not
only women but also the rights of men
and children
and right now we're at a situation
situation that uh
that hopefully during the consultations
there will be clarifications about what
those rights are our foremost priority
is
as discipline in our own ranks
and not
enforcing laws on others but enforcing
it on ourselves first and then
given it as an example for the rest of
society to follow suit so we are the
first ones and our members members if
they are
involved in such things will be the
first to be prosecuted
well i don't think people believe we are
terrorists i think it's just
the war on terror it was just a
term coined by by the united states and
anyone that
did not fall in line with label
terrorists
you